former RAF pilot and our advisor at
Universal defense and Security Solutions
at Vice Marshall Sean Bell joins us here
in the studio good to see you Sean thank
you for coming on so Ukrainian troops we
know have retaken control largely of the
Kiev region how significant is that and
indeed other areas well it looks very
likely that Kiev is still a strategic
priority for the Russians but of course
we've all seen that phase one of this
conflict
um it hasn't gone well for the Russians
and we've seen over the last couple of
days a consolidation of the Russian
positions particularly around the the
North West as they scratch their head
and try and work out what next
um literally in the last 24 hours we've
started to see uh troop redeployments
out of the area which is a key indicator
they now do have a plan B and for me the
the withdrawal from hostile airport is a
key indicator that would have been hard
fought over by the Russians and
therefore would they would not give that
up likely unless there was not going to
be any urgency to review do its assault
on Kiev in the near future Russia we
understand making key inroads in the
South intense activity there perhaps not
surprising after what Moscow had said
they were going to withdraw from more
Northerly Parts yes I think we've got to
get a bit beyond the headlines here
because obviously there's the much
advertised
um a targeting of Odessa targeting the
Fuel Depot there and this sort of
targeting would normally be a precursor
for ground forces Invasion but I remind
viewers that we're looking at odessa's a
thousand miles away from Russia and they
haven't got any land forces nearby so it
would be very difficult for them to
mount any real credible uh attack
against at the moment if you imagine you
know the 40 miles of logistics queue we
had for Kiev really difficult Odessa and
also there's something like 2500
kilometers of catacombs and caves around
Odessa that would be a major challenge
for Russian forces so I think what's
more likely with these attacks is more
of sending a strategic message to both
the International Community and to
ukrainians that Odessa is in range and
we can ask you this every day can't we
what is the end game for Putin are
things changing
well I
uh if we could get inside um Putin's
head we we would be um illuminated for
that I think it's pretty clear that he
originally wanted to take the whole of
Ukraine that hasn't worked well for him
and they've had to come up with a
revised strategy what looks most likely
in the near term is he's focusing on the
donbass region why is that because three
main reasons one of which he's been
Prosecuting that campaign for about 10
years and will want to bring that to a
conclusion he's redeploying clearly
forces from Kiev into the region but
also the logistics Supply route for the
donbass is much easier for the Russians
because clearly they're right on the
Russian border so bringing troops
bringing fuel bringing armaments across
is a lot more simple for the Russians
and by the same token a lot more
difficult than ukrainians and the third
reason is because uh we haven't really
seen much from the Russian Air Force so
far supporting its Ground Forces
probably because Ukrainian resistance
has been so good but of course when
you're this close to the Border it'll be
a lot easier for the Russian Air Force
to get involved and potentially have a
decisive role but returning to your
question until everybody understands
what Putin's new revised strategic
objectives are and until he's achieved
them we're not going to see any
negotiations meaningful negotiations
anytime soon a real waiting game all
right Sean thanks a lot